I guess uh not a reluctant car collector
but an accidental car collector because
that will come and sit and and I did a
feature film my first
12 years ago where uh the kids take me
home yeah the character gets into a cab
and talks the cabbie into driving her
across the United States and I was like
well I'm just gonna buy a cab so we
bought a cab the crew and I like the the
week before we started shooting actually
we started shooting we didn't even have
the cabs and then we finally got it we
drove it all the way across the country
it had 325 000 miles on it for the film
you actually drove actually cab the crew
went across the country with it with you
yeah yeah six uh six crew members and my
wife and I and uh yeah so after that
experience I had you know I just drove
the taxi cab around for a couple of
years and and you know you kept the
taxes yeah it was my main transport you
know around town and it had the writing
on it and all that stuff yeah in fact
one time I went to a meeting at Sony and
I was driving around the parking lot I
was late for this thing and I'm driving
around this woman stops the car this is
in this Sony you know four-story parking
lot and she goes I roll down the window
she goes can you take me to my car
and I go of course uh well I'm I mean
I'm not a real cab driver I'm uh I'm
just going to she goes oh you're an
actor
in a taxi cab
okay well can you take me to my car
anyway and I said yeah sure happened you
did so I drove this woman around like
six floors she couldn't figure out where
her car was and I dropped her off and uh
you know and then was even later to the
the meeting but uh that's hilarious
I mean just to keep your taxi and
driving a taxi all around town yeah and
how old were you this was 12 years ago
yeah yeah I think I was did I have yeah
I was I was 30 something early I'll tell
you it is I I actually directed a little
independent raunchy comedy that you know
didn't cost a ton of money to make and I
wrote it directed starred in it just
like you yeah and when I read that you
did this and take me home and your wife
is in at Amber yeah I thought I gotta
ask him how I mean because this it was
the hardest thing I've ever done I don't
know how I survived everybody was
talking to me trying to talk me out of
it they're like you won't have enough
energy to move no you'll be so exhausted
you won't and there were a couple of
days right I thought I'm not I'm saying
this it sounds like I'm sure I thought I
was going to die yeah I thought I was
going to just collapse and they're going
to bring me to the hospital yeah there's
an enormous sense of Panic it's one
thing it's funny because a couple years
later I directed an episode of
Parenthood yeah and um in this one day
where we had a process trailer we were
shooting you know Interiors of a car
with this giant you know the car is on a
giant truck bed and you know at one
point we turn around and the the energy
of the car collapses you know the the
the truck uh uh the electricity just
goes out the car shuts down we're mid
U-turn and everybody in the crew is
flipping out oh my gosh we I mean this
is crazy we got to move this stuff
around and everybody's in a panic and I
thought well this is this is new for me
because the cops are actually helping us
they're stopping traffic and instead of
us having to run from the cops which is
usually the scenario when you're in an
indie film you're like all right we're
gonna steal the scenario we're going to
steal this shot it's 11 o'clock at night
you guys look that way make sure there's
no cop cars you guys look that way make
sure there's no cop cars yeah so to be
in this set where I'm like oh no we're
legal here and we have people we have
Patrol officers protecting us from this
is like this is fun this is cake this is
that's funny you say that because I
remember I directed an episode of
Smallville and it was before I directed
a movie yeah and I was like oh my
goodness this is great this is easy but
little did I know it's easier because at
there's every department is working with
they know what to do they know where to
be they know what to do and it makes
your life
tremendously easier just the fact that
there is a department yeah exactly and
you're not like wait who do we have food
for these people oh man yeah it was it
was I remember like day one filming our
movie called back in the day and we're
uh the first ad comes up to me and said
I go what's the problem they go uh the
crew and everybody has been standing in
line waiting for lunch to be ready for
like 15 minutes and it's not ready oh
that hurts and I was like it was like
it's an independent movie and I'm in
Indiana and so we had to talk to them
and say hey food has to be ready at
exactly this time there's no other and
we just and it's just like but when
you're doing TV the Parenthood you
probably were like this is a hell of a
boy yeah no problem yeah
was it
really difficult was it the hardest
thing you've ever done directing an
independent and being the star in it and
all that yeah yeah work wise other than
raising children that's far and away the
hardest well what about working with
your wife too was that did that could
put a kind of a well she's a she was a
great sport you know like I mean I was
uh you know we were always every day was
like a new thing and uh I I I was
no actor should have put up with what I
put her through I mean it would be like
hey guys we gotta we are shooting this
scene in the forest because we had to
shift over because it was raining
somewhere else and so I was like hey we
got this scene where you're digging
through the mud trying to get your purse
that you chucked into the woods so we I
just I'm guessing there's poison ivy
here everybody get socks on and uh honey
you're just gonna have to just do it
we'll try and clear it out don't worry
about the lime and she got poison ivy so
bad that by the time we had driven out
to Utah we couldn't shoot half of her
face are you serious yeah because the
poison ivy had reached her face and so
we were like all right can't shoot
Amber's left side so uh and the whole
time she was just trying to navigate as
best and she was fine you guys didn't
fight you didn't dick her no no I mean
she at one point she was just like hey I
just need to I need to I just need a
little space here just because I'm doing
the best I can but I'm I'm itching and
we need to go to urgent care to get
shots for my you know good Lord yeah